[ Camera shutter clicking ]
-I'm Kim Kardashian West.
I'm a mother, millionaire,
law student,
and billionaire.
I'm also the proud owner
of SKIMS shapewear products.
SKIMS has given
comfort and support
to millions of women
of all shapes and sizes,
but we're just getting started.
Introducing...
new SKIMS Shapewear
for Thick Dogs,
the only product on the market
that will comfortably accentuate
your dog's curves,
no matter how thick that butt.
-Hi. I'm D'ennis, head designer
at SKIMS for Thick Dogs,
and this is my dog, Delicious.
[ Laughter ]
Now as you can see,
she ain't no toothpick.
Homegirl got a badonk
like her daddy [chuckles]
making it almost impossible
to find clothes for her --
until now.
Oh!
Now she looks so good, I can't
believe she's still with me.
[ Laughter ]
-But don't just take our word
for it.
-As a dog owner,
I was amazed
at the wide selection
of fashionable looks
for tiny, skinny dogs,
but full-figured dogs need a way
to show what
they're working with, too.
Thanks, SKIMS.
-All the other dogs used to pay
no attention to my thick dog.
But now with SKIMS,
we can't walk down the street
without rockets popping out.
[ Laughter ]
-My dog used to be ashamed
of how she looked,
but SKIMS gave her confidence,
and now she's dating
Scott Disick.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wait, t-t-these are for dogs?
-They sure are.
And SKIMS for Thick Dogs
come in all
the classic SKIMS colors.
-Like beige, brown,
and that's it.
[ Laughter ]
-Now every dog
can be a designer dog
with SKIMS for Thick Dogs.
-And they only take
like 90 minutes to put on.
-And I know
what you're thinking --
did we make those holes
where the poop comes out?
-And the answer is obviously no.
That is gross.
Get your mind out of the gutter.
[ Laughter ]
-So stop wasting all your money
getting cosmetic surgery
on your dog
and just get SKIMS.
-And turn your good girl
into a bad bitch.
-New SKIMS for thick-ass dogs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Looks so good, you'll be saying,
"Damn, am I really thinking this
about a dog right now?"